leute ich bin mal ehrlich mit euch es
ist acht uhr abends 815 und ich habe mir
vorgenommen im dezember jeden zweiten
tag ein video hochzuladen
aber habe ich vor produziert natürlich
nicht und jetzt fragt ihr euch das habe
ich aber heute sonst gemacht wartet mal
ich habe den heftigsten bauen der mit
obstsalat aufgestellt man wird nicht
klar ob es war ein schöner arbeit und
mehrere glocken hässlich aber den habe
ich schon seit drei jahren und ich
weigere mich eine richtige pfanne zu
kaufen
das ist einfach so randall dem bild
stehen über dem beauty blog an so ein
schöner blumenstrauß es bei mir sonne
es ist nikolaus und ihr habt in eurem
schulleiter bestimmt was ganz tolles
gefunden weil ihr menschen habt ihr euch
lieb haben oder auch nicht dann
willkommen im club also es ist jetzt
natürlich in vier stunden nikolaus aber
ich tue jetzt einfach mal so da ist der
nikolaus ist dachte ich weiß was besser
als ein schoko nikolaus ist das ein
schon ist der weihnachtsmann oder und da
man diese dinge am heutigen tag
wahrscheinlich zuhauf bekommt das ich
mir was kann man alles mit so einem
schoko nikolaus anstellen und dann
dachte ich vielleicht einen shake
reinmachen oder verkleinern und einen
kakao draus machen aber das wollen wir
alles zu langweilig und zu standard und
dann kam mir wirklich mir kam selber die
idee ein kuchen in den nikolaus rein
summer und da ist es ein schoko nikolaus
b
[Musik]
ich muss ein baum aus stellen zitiert
mich warum müssen denn krings immer
gemeinsam sie können auch mal schön sein
und lecker und schenkst du jemanden so
nikolaus und dann fängt er sich so und
warum ist in der st und dann macht er
hinauf und hatten kuchen im nikolaus
natürlich können wir keinen kuchenteig
in so nikolaus machen und dann in den
backofen stecken deswegen dachte ich
machen wir einen no way cache also der
wird im kühlschrank gemacht perfekt um
so ein stück weihnachtsmann zu fühlen
was braucht man für einen klassischen
obey cache alle milchprodukte die es auf
der welt gibt
mascarpone frischkäse quark sahne butter
warum ich fett geworden bin und mein
plan ist es zwei tage zu machen und den
dann immer so zu schichten wie so ein
zebra cool oder
außerdem möchte ich noch ein bisschen
spekulatius reinmachen sind für ein
quatsch und christstollen rubin ich
schon aufgemacht weil ich unbedingt
wissen wollte wie er schmeckt
[Musik]
gisela ich habe mich dazu entschlossen
sie gisela wenn ihre besseren namen
haben
ich habe gesagt gefunden gelatine steht
aber ich möchte keine gelatine benutzen
denn sonst fangen wir wieder die
diskussion an wie aus dem veganer wird
es vielleicht ich möchte diesen weg
nicht gehen zuerst wollen wir jetzt mal
frischkäse und mascarpone mission
hallo
okay das funktioniert nur bei quark
[Musik]
frischkäse kantone rhein hoch
darauf machen wir eine schoko creme und
dafür brauchen wir geschmolzene
schokolade und dafür müssen wir waren in
einem topf schmelzen
rudolf mittlerer stufe und während die
sahne waren wird werden wir schokolade
klein schneiden
es wird man richtig krasser franklin
sünde beim berühren kann die schokolade
schmerz in der ddr stellt das zum
abkühlen mal kurz nach draußen und wir
nutzen die zeit zum abkühlen um die
weiße schokolade zu schneiden
ich nehme mir jetzt den halben becher
und dem ist mir natürlich wieder unsere
weiße schokolade kann nun in den topf
die weiße schokolade sind auch einfach
aus wie flüssige butter dann hole ich
mal die dunkle schokolade und lasse
jetzt die weiße abkühlt aber wir sind
hier auch so eine kleine experimentelle
küche hier machen wir nur happy drittel
exzellenz mal rein es ist immer noch ein
bisschen klang prill
[Musik]
jetzt weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ob
sie überhaupt noch fest werden kann weil
das so viel bammel ist so aber wir
werden also sie ist auf jeden fall nicht
so flüssig wie ich dachte
und noch mal dass sie die zweite hälfte
der mascarpone freese wird später
bestimmt auch seine mama sein diese
nachts noch kuchen backt beim restart
nicolas bei krems miteinander vermischen
genug ich glaube juckte ist ein bisschen
flüssiger geworden so gisela du hast
deine arbeit getan sodass gehen so damit
ihr noch ein bisschen besser wird
braucht ihr bruder sogar genau das auch
mein ganz guter trick wenn irgendwas
feste haben wollt so ein bisschen cooler
zucker 1 passieren und dann wäre das
rein gehört die scheiße ich denke mal
das wird noch fest oder nochmal um einen
kleinen vanillecreme zu geben müssen wir
cs wann extrakt ein teelöffel ist eine
von der gsoa arbeitsfläche immer schön
sauber halten jetzt beginnt die
filigrane feinarbeit wie ich ein
bisschen oben bis in die alufolie lösen
um seiten loch rein zu machen
ich habe mein appell ist auch einfach
meinen lochabstand dafür alles für mich
riesig wie so ein chirurg viele kleine
säge das hat gut funktioniert das macht
mir den deckel ist die schokolade dick
da oben seit wann haben weihnachtsmänner
so eine dicke schokolade
diese angst dass es daran scheitert dass
der vielleicht zu dick sein könnte weil
diese diese weihnachtsmänner zb von aldi
die haben eine sehr dünne schicht naja
so weil man sie spritzten nicht finden
benutzen wir jetzt gefrierbeutel die
funktionieren sagt lacroix die
schokocreme ist richtig gut geworden
meine leute packen einfach macht keiner
keine angst für falsch als einfach
falsch was durch das wild nicht für die
reinhard meyer hahn
vielleicht kann ich kurzem später
bestimmt hat er schon
ich glaube ich dir gleich mal zu spät in
erfüllung wasser marsch
nachdem ihr ein bisschen füllungen
reingemacht gestoppt die wieder kuchen
rhein ist der schutz vor ort jetzt kommt
der deckel drauf an jetzt haben wir ihn
gefüllten weihnachtsmann und den machen
wir jetzt wieder zu sie klammern sich
nur so hart können und niemand wird
jemals erfahren dass der gefüllt ist
aber er ist extrem schnell ist jetzt mal
kurz zum späte und guckt ob der schoko
weihnachtsmänner soll ich euch gleich
was mitbringen
nicola oder so gar nichts mir meine
städtischen 3000 jahre später viele
leute story times später hatte keine
weihnachtsmänner also bin ich noch zu
einem edeka gefahren der drei millionen
kilometer entfernt brach ich habe meinen
kunden egal wie gut denn schokolade
und es geht nichts über den geruch von
billigen schoko weihnachtsmann jetzt bin
ich gespannt
genauso wollte ich den namen schön und
bei den großen hier machen wir auch den
streifen selbst versuchen wir bevor wir
in die weiße schicht reinmachen machen
jetzt eine schicht spekulatius den
krümeln wir dann den schoko
weihnachtsmann hinein soll
okay das 40 grad haben wo er ist
immerhin kommt und wenn er voll ist dann
wieder deckel drauf machte er ihn zu und
der prank ist damit perfekt und dann
kommt er natürlich über nacht in den
schon wisst ihr was weit so schöne ist
machen wir jetzt auch noch ein melker
dann haben wir gleich den test welcher
weihnachtsmann sich dafür am besten
eignet können festhalten der milka es
auf jeden fall der dienst mache jetzt
mal ohne kurven macht man nur mit drinks
schicht so zeigt das schon ganz gut
verrate niemanden diesem plan und weil
wir noch so viel zeit übrig haben wenn
wir jetzt einen richtigen know by kecken
nachrichten springform 8 ehrlich gesagt
auch ein bisschen angst die
weihnachtsmänner nichts werden deswegen
so unglaublich ist verboten trafen wir
specker abziehen
so jetzt nämlich ein bisschen butter und
packen ist unser kicks mischung seine
hände nehmen wir diese flügel im drücken
sie auf unseren gucken platz so wenn ihr
das jetzt da und machen boden verteilt
habt kommt unsere ultra weiße krempe oma
sieht das cool ist sünde alte das ist so
und wir hoffen einfach mal dass er fest
wird und jetzt kommt ein kühlschrank den
dunklen tag machen wir so eine
christstollen spekulatius mit lungen ist
richtig schöne resteverwertung oft da
ich bin wie meine mutter geworden die
nach zusätzlicher und backen doch so
gewohntes spiel ich gehe jetzt schlafen
und morgen wieder und für euch ist aber
nur ein schnitt um nächsten tag die
weihnachtsmänner sind happy
nikolaus über die und wenn man schon
nichts geschenkt bekommt man beschenkt
man sich selbst mit vier train
weihnachtsmann ich würde mal sagen wie
schneiden die dinge jetzt auf ich möchte
ihn gern in dieser mitte hier schneiden
damit man mit das leichte geben ist auf
jeden fall die überraschung über lasst
uns aber nicht unterkriegen
der milka weihnachtsmann hat kuhflecken
wir halten fest der mega weihnachtsmann
ist ebenfalls am besten halbieren aber
leider ist unser leben nicht fest
geworden aber jetzt könnte man das zum
beispiel auf dem teller legen und
auslöffeln das wäre eine idee keine gute
aber ich lege den mal ins gefrierfach
damit die weiße creme festwirt
rechtsextreme pnos so jetzt mal nur als
beispiel
dann könnt ihr jetzt hier steht und mein
gott
kennt ihr großer diese eier die man so
aus windkraft von milka genauso also ich
würde sagen nur ein halber verhältnis
jetzt ganz ehrlich das war sprenger mich
selbst habe ich wirklich gedacht dass
das funktioniert ich lasse ihnen jetzt
mal zwei stunden früher vielleicht
passiert ja noch ein wunder
und dann sehen uns gleich wieder 2000
jahre später
ich hab das videos genau bis zu dieser
stelle geschnitten und dann ist mir
aufgefallen moment mal werden die kugel
noch gar nicht probiert und wir sollten
noch einmal in den letzten
weihnachtsfeier aufschneiden der den
halben tag in der gefriertruhe verbracht
hat ich möchte einfach nicht schreiben
dass dieses video ein fake ist ich
glaube ich hatte noch nie ein feld auf
dem kanal
das sieht auf jeden fall auf den ersten
blick cool aus jetzt muss er nur noch
nicht gut abschnitten
also ich sag mal so der aufwand lohnt
sich glaube ich nicht fürs ergebnis kein
wunder dass ich diese idee noch nicht
auf intourist oder so gefunden habe denn
die sorten scheiße
wir wollen aber trotzdem wissen wie es
schmeckt irgendwie cool aber empfehle
ich euch absolut nicht zum nachmachen
und damit wir aus diesem video mit einem
positiven gefühl heraus gehen können
schauen wir jetzt mal was aus den kunden
geworden ist der show ist oder für brett
der boden aus spekulatius und
christstollen und an diese schokocreme
unsere auf leute und um jetzt richtig
anzugeben myelom ist cacau bei dem
hellen habe ich die vermutung dass die
creme soweit sein wird
ja das ist er so ein gescheitertes
experiment unseren auffällig dass ich
richtig mit dem kopf um drauf als begin
to the lord my christmas ich bin gerade
so froh dass ich den gemacht habe der
teig schmeckt total lecker durch den
christstollen und spekulatius ist so
eine masse geworden
die schokocreme ist super lecker
das kakaopulver um noch drauf perfekt
ich hoffe euch hat die folge gefallen
auch wenn es ein riesenchaos war und
wenn dem so ist dann gibt mir doch bitte
einen daumen nach oben
aber mit meinen kanalfest ist noch nicht
getan habt um keine videos mehr zu
verpassen aktiviert die glocke und keine
videos mehr zu verpassen
aktiviert bei der glocke aktivieren um
keine videos mehr zu verpassen und wir
sehen uns dann übermorgen ist dann wie
sie richtig instagram richtig ernst